I want to start today with some
genuinely good economic news and the
News itself is a very small data point
but there's a bigger story here and it's
the story first and foremost about how
is the economy doing right now that gets
us to what will the impact of the
economy be on the midterms
if people accurately understand the
state of the economy because it's about
the perception of the economy more than
the economy itself that affects how
people vote and then the bigger
conversation which I think continues to
be a very interesting one is what in
general can we say about the state of
the American economy when there's a
democrat in the White House versus when
there's a republican in the white house
so come along for the journey let's you
know rather than starting at thirty
thousand feet and getting down to the
runway excuse the analogy let's start at
the base and then get up to thirty
thousand feet so economic news good news
GDP has accelerated in the United States
at 2.6 percent in the third quarter we
just got these numbers remember the
third quarter uh is July August
September and we get those numbers at
the end of the following month which is
now the end of October expectation for
GDP growth was 2.3 percent the actual
number was 2.6 percent so
having an increase rather than a
decrease by standard economic metrics
where we want indefinite growth I know
uh it's good to have GDP growth and then
when it is better than the expectation
then it is considered even better and
indeed the stock market is reacting to
this uh quite favorably as of this
particular moment uh when we are filming
the Dow Jones Industrial Average is up
over 500 points and we will see where
the day finishes out a narrowing trade
deficit and increases in consumer
spending and government outlays boosted
the number all normal a sharp pullback
in housing subtracted from the number
part of a broader decline in private
investment consumer spending decelerated
increasing at just a 1.4 percent Pace in
the quarter down from two percent so
understand that oftentimes the reports
on this stuff are so unclear consumer
spending decelerated might make some
think that consumer spending is down it
is not it grew at a slightly lower rate
than in the previous quarter so the
obvious question when we get such
numbers is this must be terrible for
Democrats right how will Democrats and
Joe Biden ever survive this obviously
good news that's a joke one of my
followers on Twitter said something like
the way Fox News will report it is is
the economy doing better right now
because people expect Republicans to
take over in November so they are
spending now because they know the
economy will be better once republi it's
a joke but it wouldn't be completely
foreign to Fox News to pull something
like that so that's the GDP number let's
let's now take a look at the broader
economy we have an economy where we have
uh better than expected GDP growth
historically low unemployment to the
point where one could argue we are
within a few tenths of a point of what
we would consider full employment
Remember full employment isn't every
single person has a job
uh but by the economic definition of
Full Employment we're very close to that
uh consumer demand continues to grow
albeit at a slightly slower rate than it
did in the second quarter and there is
still high inflation of course there's
no there's no need to exclude that from
our analysis or to pretend that that's
not going on so it's becoming very
difficult to make the case that this is
a terrible economy but Republicans are
still doing it and that's what gets us
to the impact on the November election
there was a point
eight weeks ago ten weeks ago something
like that where the number of Americans
who said abortion access and the
overturning of Roe v Wade are top issues
in terms of the midterms
that has diminished and has been
supplanted by the economy which at the
end of the day in most elections it's
the economy that regularly rates as the
most important issue now sensible people
like many of you would say well David
the economy is doing well most economic
indicators are very good inflation's
high but everything else looks great
clearly on the strength of the economy
Democrats are going to do really well in
November right
not necessarily what matters is the
perception of the economy and by
straight up telling lies and focusing
only on inflation Republicans have
convinced many voters that we have a bad
economy right now
uh nearly full employment GDP growth
choppy but not crazy stock market but
many voters believe that there's
something very wrong with the economy
and if indeed they do believe that it
wouldn't be unexpected for them to vote
for Republicans since they are the out
party currently in terms of power in the
White House House and Senate this then
gets us to the last thing I want to
discuss a little bit which is in general
does the economy do better under
Democratic or republican presidents the
data are extraordinarily clear on this
don't trust me do your own research on
this but if you look historically
in the modern political era on average
the stock market does better under
democratic presidents job growth is
stronger under democratic presidents the
unemployment rate is lower under
democratic presidents GDP growth is
greater under democratic presidents
inflation is lower under democratic
presidents are there exceptions yes
um but that is an undeniable reality now
you will often hear talking points from
the right when confronted with this
undeniable data where they will say
things like well that's because a lot of
democratic presidents had the benefit of
a republican-controlled house to rein
them in such statements have been
evaluated empirically and they are
without Merit sometimes you will hear
well there's a lag time so really like
the first six months of a democratic
Administration are the economic result
of the previous administration which
might have been a republic it's been
studied
and there is no empirical evidence
suggesting that so don't take my word
for it unlike many others I don't tell
you that I hold the ultimate and unique
truth or a monopoly on the data or a
monopoly on evaluating the data do the
research yourself I've done it myself
I've made the spreadsheets myself and
I've looked at it closely
and unless I have lost every ability to
interpret even the most basic data
um this is the reality that I've
presented to you fact check me tell me
if you find something different